sometimes you see once you spotted this
you like see it everywhere in graphic
design you'll sometimes see a design
with like
three
or more gears that are sort of supposed
to be meshing together sometimes what
you see i i guess i'll draw just sort of
wheels like this but they're supposed to
have teeth like this and then there'll
be another one here
and another one here and this is
supposed to be like
you know three things that are working
together the students and the teachers
and the parents all come together to
make the school work fantastically or
whatever it is and you look at this
thing
and if you think about what happens with
gears
right so if this one say this one's
going this way then because this these
two the teeth are meshing this way this
one has to go this way
so that they you know because they have
to turn against each other
and then what's this one's supposed to
do
this one is saying that it's supposed to
go around that way and this one is
supposed to say it's supposed to go
around that way and so nothing works and
so your school district
grinds to a halt or whatever it is if
you happen to have a british two pound
coin and you look on the back of it
you'll see there's this design
with gears and various other things
about technology and the industrial
revolution so if you look closely
there's like 19 well if you count them i
guess you can't look and immediately
count 90. but if you count them like
there's there's 19 of these gears and 19
is odd so like it goes this way it goes
this way it goes this way odd means that
it won't work so you know your
symbol of technological process or
whatever it's like it doesn't move so
the question is well how do you get
three
gears that do move is there a way to
change the shape
like you can't do it in the plane but if
you go out of the plane then what can
you do so here's a few
mechanisms that that show ways that you
can make this together so these are
these are like uh worm gears
you get this sort of screw helix thing
and then the way that they work well you
can see that it works and they're all
sort of symmetrical around
let's see maybe if you look
directly down here you can see that
there's a symmetry between them right so
these three sort of worm gears because
the way that they interact they don't
have a direction in the same way as as
planar gears do as gears just on the
plane and so you can get them to all
work like this although you do require
this frame so so so this is another
solution to the problem
wasn't really a problem that needed
solving but there you go so this is
again it's three gears
that turn together and they're sort of
meshing with each other but they have
this other weird
feature that they're all linking with
each other so they're sort of linked
gears they stay in place you can
actually you can't actually turn one of
them
without turning all of them at once it
doesn't it doesn't move it's me and and
saul schleimer is a guy who i work with
these things so we made this thing and
immediately people say okay sure you can
make it go but can you like drive it
with a motor and then
what we ended up figuring out is like so
here's
um another sort of helical
uh worm screw thing and then
whoops
so you can see that it's sort of
climbing down and as it's going it's
making making them go um
but actually so to answer the question
about how do you make it drive itself so
here's this uh there's this sort of base
that you can put it on
and the gears just sort of slide in
there
and then
if you pull this through then it makes
it go or if you just turn it but this
helix thing turning is sort of the same
thing as moving it as translating it so
if you turn it it makes the gears go
or if you push it through then it also
makes the gears go
this is sort of a
another variant on that same idea
these gears aren't rotating gears
they're sort of sliding gears all of
these have like a an axis of symmetry so
there you go
so
so these i mean you can see these these
teeth that make it make it do that let's
see if i can do this weird thing let's
see so so that the illusion if i move it
just right is it the one that i'm not
holding
doesn't move
i know if you're getting that so the one
the one that i'm not touching is
supposed to sort of hover in the middle
and while the other ones move there's
sort of a weird effect because
because it doesn't look like i'm
directly controlling it i don't know how
good i'm doing that oh you can you can
fix this in post right you can just
stabilize on it and then you'll be fine
right of the gaps between the primes as
well you see some are short
oh that was nice that was satisfying a
nice long gap it's really nice i i mean
it's it's a bit of silly fun there's no
practical use to it or anything but i
i'd love it